[Applause]
Wow that's how this community responded
that's how these survivors and these
family members are coping thank you all
so much I know that though I want to
thank the LGBT Center for the quilts to
make sure that we had the photos and the
names this beautiful quilt that they
lend to us today to be able to honor
everyone so I want to make sure I thank
them as well and the women's Bible study
has made rainbow ribbons that they'll be
tying on the peace pole out here just
after as well so we're gonna have a
closing prayer there the group will tie
the rainbow ribbons and then for those
of you the like the churches opened up
the sanctuary for time of reflection and
peace if you'd like to go in there and
pray if you'd like to go in there and
just sit with each other the families
that go in you're welcome to do that and
once again thank you
first United Methodist Church so very
much for opening your heart in your home
and God's home and letting everyone know
that God loves all and all means all
thank you Pastor would you like to come
up for closing prayer I'm not sure if
Shelli or Pastor Bob beverage Shelley
thank you
let us pray gracious and loving God and
this remembrance of grief and loss we
give you thanks for this community whom
you have knit together in strength and
courage to send a message that is
different than the one that was sent
three years ago that we will continue to
be love to one another that we will
continue to show to shine the light of
peace in this community that all people
will know that they are beloved that
they are beautiful creations of you and
that nothing can take that away from
them we give you thanks for this
opportunity to gather together to be
strength for one another and to tell the
stories of all those who were lost but
their memory and legacy will live on in
our hearts and in this community we pray
this in your name Amen
again thank you they'll be tying the
rainbow ribbon to the peace pole which
is around to the right I want to make
sure that we thank the more than 460
other entities around the world I want
to make sure on behalf of Maria and
Mayra especially that we thank Peru and
Ecuador and Brazil and Mexico and so
many this is around the globe that this
is happening right now that are standing
with us and Maria wanted to make sure
that I said thank you and Maria I know
you're watching now we honor Jerry thank
you for championing this cause this
concludes our service thank you all
[Applause]